just happened in the last few minutes
Nadine Doris now we've known her as a
politician over the past few years for
being a staunch Boris Johnson loyalist
um she's not a huge fan of Rishi soon
actually served under Boris Johnson as
the culture secretary we understand
today that she is standing down as an MP
she has just tweeted three minutes ago I
haven't I have today informed the chief
whip that I'm standing down as the MP
for Mid bedfordshire with immediate
effect it has been an honor to serve as
the MP for such a wonderful constituency
but it is now a time for someone younger
to take the reins now the context I
think of all of this is first of all
that she has certainly fallen out of
favor she really backed Boris Johnson
um she was one of his closest allies
even in the dying day she was one of the
only MPS that was prepared to go on TV
and to uh back him even as it seemed
like his Premiership was collapsing and
she's been an MP for quite a long time
2005 she was elected in mid bedfordshire
she has served in the cabinet and now
she has well over the past year or so
she has seemed to Pivot more towards a
TV career rather than politics and
hasn't been around uh certainly as much
in Westminster and in Parliament and as
she had been previously so that might be
behind her decision the other part of
this of course is that she was rumored
to be being lined up for a peerage by
Boris Johnson in the honors list we are
expecting that honors list to be
released at some point
um today although we haven't seen it yet
but it does seem like there has maybe
been a bit of back and forth behind the
scenes over Nadine Doris being awarded a
peerage and the um and her standing down
as an MP to be able to take that period
there have been rumors circulating
Westminster that maybe the the current
prime minister Rishi sunak who signs off
um that honors list put forward by Boris
Johnson had asked some names to be
removed for certain reasons some of the
MPS the suggestion was he didn't want a
by-election to be triggered well if you
look at that tweet today she has
informed the chief whip that she's
standing down as the MP for Mid
bedfordshire with immediate effect that
means that at some point there will have
to be a by-election in her constituency
now the thing to um the thing to look at
of course is who will challenge her it
does seem like
um she has quite a big uh quite a big
majority in that constituency but we'll
have to
um we'll have to check on that to see
who would challenge her uh sorry I
haven't had a look actually at the um
the majority in their constituency this
just last
um happened in the last few minutes but
that will be the the talk in Westminster
who will Who will take her on the last
thing that we should soon at the Prime
Minister wants at the moment is a
by-election but I'm afraid uh this uh
surprise resignation from Nadine Doris
is going to trigger on uh I don't think
the Prime Minister will be very happy
the interesting thing will be when we
hear from Nadine Doris what are her
reasons uh behind standing down and at
the moment all we know is that she will
be standing down with immediate effect
um as I say she's been in mp since 2005.
Boris Johnson loyalist she plans not to
stand at the next general election
and I've just been told she has a 24 000
majority in mid bedfordshire so the if
the by-election when the by-election is
triggered that is a huge majority that
seems like the type of seat that the
conservatives should be able to hang on
to
um but of course we never know what's
going to happen in politics particularly
uh with the polls at the way they are
with the conservative party in a
difficult uh position uh but that will
all be very interesting the last thing
that Richie's seen at once but it's
happening Nadine is standing down today
she won't stand to the next election